diplomats from russia ukraine germany
and france are trying to resolve the
crisis over ukraine the u.s meantime is
talking tough on sanctions to discourage
russia from invading ukraine and of
course this comes as more than 100 000
russian troops hold at the ukrainian
border and with the face-off between
political leaders getting all the
attention what do the ukrainian people
make of this ramp up intentions here to
share some insights is adrian
karatnitsky board member of the
ukrainian institute of america and
contributing editor of american purpose
he formerly headed the u.s human rights
group freedom house adrian thank you so
much for being here let's get into it
right ukrainian leaders are portraying
tensions on the border as par for the
course are ukrainians interpreting it
that way or are tensions beginning to
escalate at all
in general i think ukrainians are
staying calm
and not panicking but there has been a
little bit of movement the currency has
depreciated seven or eight percent in
the last few weeks while maintaining
stability throughout the last year and
you have to keep in mind that since
april there have been roughly between 80
and 130 000 troops on ukraine's eastern
borders massed potentially for an
onslaught and the the country has
accepted this as a normal thing because
they've already
been a part of a war where 15 000 nearly
15 000 people have died so i think that
both the idea that russia is a threat
and that russia is massed at the borders
has become unfortunately a routine part
of ukraine's life
yeah it's part of the daily normal and
it's something that's disturbing that
it's become part of the daily normal um
this relative calm i guess you could
call it that ukrainians might feel
how much of it
emanates from the leadership at the
moment and i wonder to what extent that
is an economic strategy you know keep
the markets calm keep people calm
or is it a move to
avoid panic and avoid provoking moscow
to making a rash move somehow
well i think it's a combination of these
things no leader would like to set off
a panic and in fact ukraine's resilience
in the face of this makes it easier i
think i i don't think it's so much the
president although he has made
reassuring comments and the leaders of
the defense ministry and the national
security council have similarly
downplayed the imminence of the threat
but i really think it's the ukrainian
people who are
calm cool and collected uh and i think
you see it in various ways number one
there isn't any
anti-russian hysteria there are many
russians who are intermarried with
ukrainians there's no ethnic tension uh
people interact in ukrainian and in
russian and ukrainians accept the idea
that they're a
multinational country in which of course
the overwhelming majority of people are
ukrainian citizens but i think that the
atmosphere is pretty relaxed for a
country that in effect has been in a
wartime footing and face this threat for
eight years on it
right but it's kind of a case of we've
seen this all before i mean if this is
the norm for the russian ukrainian
relationship at least domestically for
myself and my friends it kind of feels
like we know this tension has been going
on but what was the singular moment what
was the impetus in the history of this
relationship between these two areas
that got us to where we are today
well i think it's by a certain set of
events a gentleman by the name of
vladimir putin
came to the
to the ascended to the top of the
russian leadership and rebuilt
a
basically single world a single leader
authoritarian or
you know dictatorship where he calls all
the shots and he has evolved a kind of a
two
two major sort of ideas in his
government one is that the collapse of
the soviet union was a was a bad thing
and somehow has to be reversed and two
that ukrainians don't really exist that
their linguistic difference is their
distinct culture all those things are
not actually true that this is some sort
of a fake construction that was
concocted by the austro-hungarians in
the 19th century and it goes against the
trap the thread of ukrainian history for
a millennium
tell us a little bit more about the
ukrainian culture versus the russian
culture because i think it's something
that we don't really understand very
well in the us
yeah so the ukrainians are kind of like
the kurds they've rarely had a stable
state they had a period of statehood uh
kind of quasi statehood under cossack
headmans but they were also under the
polish lithuanian commonwealth they were
under austro-hungary they were under
russia they were under the
tatars so they've been under the ottoman
empire so they've had a number of rulers
and leaders whereas russia has primarily
been russia meaning that the current
configuration of russia has been
primarily russia so ukrainians have
grown up as much with western or central
european influence on their culture
including the catholic world uh as have
uh unlike the russians so there's a
there's a big distinction in the sense
because ukraine was uh and also there's
a kind of a tradition of democracy even
the cossack uh leaders of the 17th and
18th centuries they had they were
elected by councils of their uh of their
units of their military units that uh
and they were patrons of the arts and
they built churches and they built
museums and they endowed education
so there's a little bit of a different
development i would say there's more of
a european the influence of the latin
language the influence european culture
is more pronounced than it was in
development
it feels like i want to talk about other
countries getting involved it feels as
though germany is trying to do a little
bit of a switzerland vibe and be a
little bit more
waffling a bit on its involvement if
germany continues to not get as involved
what does that mean for german relations
with the us and for other european
nations yeah well germany you know the
us is trying to put germany on side
president uh
biden made a major concession to germany
by
deciding not to impose sanctions on the
north stream uh gas pipeline i actually
do advise the ukrainian oil and gas
companies i want to declare that
interest but the fact is that that was a
gesture not to the russians but to
angela merkel and to the germans in the
hope that they would be more
accommodating in the face of putin's
aggressive recent aggressiveness that
hasn't really uh quite
worked out i do think there is some
potential tension in in the uh in the in
the bilateral uh relationship but i
don't think it's it's over i think one
of the issues that has to be understood
is that germany thinks that
it invaded russia as the soviet union
but in fact six million ukrainians died
the largest proportion of people who
died in the second world war as a result
of nazi aggression where of course jews
but ukrainians and belarusians came
second and third proportionally they
wiped out six million souls on the on
the territory what today's is ukraine
and uh but the germans seem to feel that
they owe the russians some uh
currency and i think that they equally
owe the ukrainian some currency and
unfortunately russian soft power and
russian propaganda has built this image
in the minds of many germans and i think
it's now important to kind of break down
that image and get a more realistic view
of what german obligations are to its
neighbors to the east
i want to go back to what you said about
how you consult for ukrainian energy
companies because there's a huge role
here for natural gas and and the fact
that russia supplies so much of it to
germany the biden administration has
already been making alternative plans in
case russia does cut off fuel sales to
other countries
and i wonder
what would be the catalyst for that
happening and from where you sit what
would need to happen
already was pinching on the spot markets
was pinching europe and reducing uh
supplies uh keeping the supplies from
the existing pipelines to 50 of their
capacity or even less
secondly russia could if tensions
be became even more pronounced could
really squeeze the caps and uh i think
they're generally short of a war and the
imposition of new sanctions i think
russia would more or less be playing
with the spot markets rather and with uh
on which partially germany is reliant i
mean germany and mrs merkel made them
made the decision to wean themselves off
of the nuclear power and that made them
much more dependent on russian natural
gas and i think they also rejected the
idea of building lng capacity because
they thought it would be too expensive
and not worth it uh and i think poland
and other countries that understood the
geopolitical threat diversified and have
more inputs by which to import uh
natural gas and i think this is an
opportunity for u.s business uh for the
lng sector to ramp up and to
strategically meet the demands ukraine
and europe have large storage capacities
and creating a strategic reserve of gas
to allow for these kinds of
periods of tension i think is the next
item on the agenda
big picture here in our final minute
together adrian a lot of experts we've
had on the show have said that calling
this a potential world war ii event is
going to bridge too far how would you
describe it
well i don't think it's a potential
world war ii event but it is you know
one of the great benefits of the
collapse of the soviet union was a kind
of a of a kind of a peace dividend at
least in the in the european theater and
i think that that peace dividend if
ukraine were to be somehow pacified and
reoccupied by russia in a very bloody
war apart from the many years of
instability that would throw into europe
europe and european markets would create
a permanent
reviving superpower a military
superpower that would have a much more
aggressive stance russia has demographic
problems with its
european population a big rise in the
muslim and turkic population and i think
they want to have a bigger slavic core
and i think that's part of their uh
strategy and if they were able if putin
succeeded we have a brand new kind of a
new soviet union uh with more market uh
oomph and
a firmer command of of energy resources
and i think it would be a huge problem
going forward for europe and for the us
it would be a major strategic challenge
that's why you're so important yeah
counterweight really to uh the western
world then adrian thank you so much
adrian karanicki is board member of the
ukrainian institute of america he is
also editor of american purpose